hi I'm Betsy I'm a tasty producer and
today I'm going to show you how to make
my ice cube chocolate cups you'll fill
up each muffin tin slot with water and
then place a popsicle stick in each slot
you'll freeze them until solid and then
while your water is freezing you'll make
your fillings and your melted chocolate
I chose three different fillings for
this video
the first filling I chose was peanut
butter like a peanut butter or cream
cheese based mousse with this recipe I
kind of wanted to channel my inner
chocolatier the second filling is
cookies and cream so good another reason
why I chose three fillings was really to
inspire you to get creative with your
own fillings maybe you don't want to do
peanut butter cookies or cream or dark
chocolate but maybe you want to do a
cheesecake filling like that that would
be really cool or even like a like a
chocolate chip cookie dough that would
be amazing just get creative in your
kitchen you're bound to find something
that's super delicious works for you and
works for your family and friends
[Music]
I've crushed the chocolate sandwich
cookies in a ziplock bag but you can
easily put them in a food processor or
blender if you would prefer not to use a
plastic bag and then the final filling
is like a chocolate pudding balance of
like the bittersweet chocolate with
something sweet like a raspberry and
then a little scent of a mint is just so
delicious so I used three different
types of melted chocolate for this
recipe each chocolate corresponds with
its designated filling if you will
obviously you can get kind of creative
with your own melted chocolate if you
prefer one chocolate over the other you
don't want to fully submerge the ice
cube into the chocolate covering it
entirely otherwise you lose the cup
shape and voila time to fill for this
recipe I've used milk chocolate dark
chocolate and white chocolate when
you're melting your chocolate you really
want to be careful not to melt your
chocolate on high in the microwave
because that will cause your chocolate
to seize so it won't really get that
super smooth like ribbony effect you
want to melt your chocolate probably on
medium power and stir every 30 seconds
this will ensure that your chocolate
doesn't seize and get that super clumpy
not so attractive texture you want that
smooth ribbony like oh my gosh I
literally just want to pour this in my
mouth texture I never thought in a
million years I'd be filling up a muffin
tin with water to create ice cubes to
dip in melted chocolate to create
something that could be sold in like a
high-end chocolate shop in Beverly Hills
you know